la bombe est tombée un peu plus tard
entre la châtaigne et ce couple c'est
une histoire d'amour qui dure
bernard et mathilde apiculteurs
professionnels place leurs ruches dans
cette châtaigneraie aux arbres
bicentenaires depuis plus de vingt ans
de châtaignier c'est un arbre on ne met
aucun traitement dessus donc là c'est
vraiment un miel qui est indemne de tout
pesticide et puis le châtaignier quand
il fleurit produit énormément de pollen
et ça pour le développement des colonies
c'est très important
ils ramassent énormément de pollen sur
les châtaigniers et puis le service
rendu par les abeilles c'est une bonne
pollinisation donc une bonne production
de châtaignes de baisse mais le couple a
acheté la chataigneraie de ses abeilles
il y a cinq ans pour se diversifier
depuis les 15 premiers jours d'octobre
ces ramassages pour filer jusqu'à 700 kg
de châtaignes les bonnes années là on a
une trentaine de vieux châtaigniers qu'
entre 250 et 300 ans qui ont été
exploitées pendant des décennies et des
décennies pour commercialiser quand il y
avait les bonnes années en châtaignes
grillées sur orléans et en région
parisienne mais il n'y a jamais eu la
transformation de la châtaigne telles
que la valorisation de la châtaigne
telle qu'on la trouve en ardèche où ou
dans les gares ou en corse pour
valoriser leur cheftaine de sologne
le couple a investi dans plusieurs
machines les blogueuses est apportée
directement dans la châtaigneraie
une fois toutes les châtaignes et bogey
elles sont triées par taille
c'est alors la calibreuse qui prend le
relais les grosses châtaignes sont
transformés en crème de marron en soupe
ou en terrine les petites jusque-là non
valorisés servent à fabriquer de la
farine
c'est un produit d'avenir dans le sens
où elle permet de ce qui est intéressant
avec la châtaigne c'est que ça permet de
re diversifier notre alimentation
c'est à dire que sans forcément chercher
à éliminer tout tout tout tout les
aliments habituels
qu'on a toujours consommer comme comme
le blé elle va venir enrichir nos
assiettes et nos régimes alimentaires
une farine sans gluten au petit goût de
noisette
c'est un produit que leurs clients
habituels leur demander alors ils se
sont lancés cette année elle a fabriqué
eux-mêmes